and so even though it is a little foggy
we're still good to go now for some
reason we don't get to launch today we
do have a backup opportunity tomorrow at
9 37 a.m eastern time so we're now just
under T minus 13 minutes and Counting
let's take a closer look at the Falcon
heavy vehicle that will deliver the ussf
44 payload to its intended orbit
Falcon heavy is essentially three Falcon
9 Rockets strapped together meaning it
can carry much larger payloads not only
to Earth orbit but to the moon and Mars
as well like the Falcon 9. Falcon heavy
is a two-stage launch vehicle the big
difference is that the Falcon heavy
first stage is comprised of three cores
and Falcon 9 only has one
Falcon heavy has 28 engines making it
the world's most powerful operating
internal power
their call out indicating that the
spacecraft is now on internal power so
with the 20 engines this makes Falcon
heavy the world's most powerful
operational rocket by a factor of two
each of these cores has nine m1d engines
making for a total of 27 engines across
all three boosters as you see there in
that shot
the 28th engine is a Merlin vacuum
engine on the second stage and that's
what will power the payload to its final
targeted orbit
altogether the Merlin 1D engines at the
base of Falcon heavy produced 5 million
pounds of thrust equal to 18 747s at
takeoff in fact the engines produce so
much power that we don't even run them
at full thrust all at once we do that
after liftoff
now after liftoff at about two and a
half minutes into flight those two side
boosters will separate from the center
core and come back to earth for
simultaneous Landings at Landing Zone 1
and Landing Zone 2 which we have a
beautiful view there on your screen if
successfully recovered the side boosters
will be refurbished and used in a future
National Security space launch
upon side booster separation the center
core will keep firing for about 90
seconds before shutting down its engines
then perform a standard stage separation
from the second stage
we will not be attempting to land our
Center core today as the mission
requires more performance meaning in
order to get our payload where it needs
to go for today's Mission the center
core will burn the fuel that we would
typically use for recovery
for those of you looking closely even
though it is a little foggy that's why
you don't see any Landing legs or grid
fins on the center core you'll probably
get a better view of that after liftoff
now moving up to the second stage once
the first stage and second stage
separate it will Propel our payload to
its intended orbit at our customers
request we will not be showing views of
stage two so immediately after the
Merlin vacuum engine on the second stage
fires up we'll be directing all of our
attention to the landing of our side
boosters
now above the second stage is where our
payload is safely enclosed inside the
fairing the fairing protects the payload
from aerothermal loads Heating and
contamination during Ascent once we
reach the vacuum of space we will
jettison the fairing as the second stage
continues its journey to orbit we will
be attempting to recover the fairing
halves today with our recovery vessel
Doug
as I mentioned earlier today's launch is
ussf 44 and that's for the National
Security it's a national security space
launch mission for the United States
space force now let's learn a little bit
more from our customer about the mission
at hand
[Music]
we depend on Space every day to support
our way of life
our supply chain Financial systems
weather tracking and power grids as well
as air land and Maritime infrastructure
our U.S military is the strongest and
best equipped force in the world
[Music]
in the heavily contested space domain
space systems command leads a team of
roughly 15 000 Guardians Airmen
civilians and contractors
headquartered in El Segundo California
our unbeatable team operates from
multiple locations across the U.S and
includes two space launch deltas
sld45 at Patrick space force base and
sld 30 at Vandenberg space Force Base
through Unity of effort across the space
acquisition Enterprise space systems
command delivers to war Fighters
integrated and resilient space
capabilities through five program
Executive offices
assured access to space procure's launch
services and delivers on-orbit
capabilities faster and more frequently
than ever before while sustaining ranges
for the United States space force and
Commercial partners
battle management command control and
communication delivers tactical and
operational command and control
capabilities to war Fighters
facilitating timely and quality battle
space decisions for the joint all domain
fight
space domain awareness and combat power
maximizes the full characterization of
space using a wide range of multi-domain
assets by rapidly detecting potential
and real threats to our nation and
allies which enables decisive action in
the space domain
Communications and positioning
navigation and timing ensures the
delivery of resilient capabilities
across the acquisition life cycle from
prototypes to systems on the production
line to systems our war Fighters have
been operating for years
space sensing delivers space-based
battle space awareness through missile
warning tracking environmental
monitoring and tactical intelligence
surveillance and reconnaissance
our adverse series fully intend to
disrupt degrade and destroy the U.S and
our allies ability to access and operate
in space
not on our watch
space systems command is focused on
creating and sustaining resilient
lethality and space through systems
integration
Unity of effort and digital engineering
ecosystems
at space systems command space starts
here
we're now at almost T minus six minutes
and 30 seconds and the SpaceX team
continues to count down for launch of
our third operational Falcon heavy
flight and all systems remain go at this
point in time fuel load is complete on
the second stage as well as one of the
side boosters and there we just heard
the call out that the fuel load is now
complete on one of the other side
booster as well as the center core
now following a successful static fire
last Thursday Falcon heavy rolled out to
the pad with a payload yesterday and
went vertical about six hours later you
can see a time lapse of that there on
your screen before we begin the webcast
today the SpaceX launch director pulled
the members of the launch Team and got a
go for prop loading and launch which as
I just mentioned were currently
undergoing we're loading propellant on
all three first stage boosters and the
second stage
now you may be able to hear the live
rocket sounds from our launch pad the
pops and hissings that you hear are from
the propellant loading as well as the
launch Mount and strong back that the
propellant is flowing through Falcon
heavy uses two propellants refined form
of kerosene called rp1 or rocket
propellant one and that's the fuel and
locks or liquid oxygen for the oxidizer
an oxidizer is a type of chemical that a
fuel requires in order to burn the
liquid oxygen is chilled below its
boiling point so that it has a much
greater amount of mass per volume
basically we can load more of it into
the rocket
our fuel is rp1 essentially a purified
kerosene it is safe easily available and
has a lot of history as a fun fact the
Saturn V first stage phone from this
very pad for Moon missions also use
liquid oxygen and carrots and heavy
tanks are pressing for strong back
retract and then we just heard the call
we are preparing for that strong back
retraction now in addition to the two
propellants I mentioned we also use the
chemical t-tep or triethyl aluminum and
triethyl boring as an ignition Source
the combustion of rp1 and locks is what
makes the rocket go up and it's the
t-tab that basically sets the match for
that propellant mix strong back low airs
begin
and we can see uh there on your screen
shortly that we will begin to see that
strong back begin to retract away from
the fairing
in preparation for that retraction the
clamped arms around the second stage
opened and that allows the strong back
to recline away from the vehicle
now as I mentioned earlier this is our
first Falcon heavy flight in three years
and a lot will happen in the first four
minutes of flight first we will light
the two side boosters followed by the
center core then about 40 seconds after
liftoff we will decrease power on the
two side boosters in preparation for Max
Q after which Falcon heavy will then
throttle is complete
never heard the call out that one of
these side boosters is now complete with
its locked load fully loaded with all of
its propellants
and then it looks like we can see that
strong backward traction happening yeah
we are now fully loaded with locks on
the other side booster
so two minutes into flight we will again
reduce thrust on the two side boosters
this time to decrease for forces on the
rocket structure overall the vehicle at
that point in time will be much lighter
but the thrust remains constant at two
and a half minutes into flight we fully
turn off the side boosters with the
booster engine cutoff or beco this
pneumatics load is complete and there we
heard the call up stage one lock so it's
complete so at this point in time both
side boosters and the center 4 are now
fully loaded with its liquid oxygen and
rp1
uh once clear of the side boosters uh
the center core will throttle up to full
power and until the center core shuts
down with main engine cutoff or Mikko
and then separate from the second stage
around the four minute mark from that
point on very similar to Falcon 9
Mission side boosters will be making
their way back to Earth for Recovery the
fairing will separate and the second
stage will take the ussf-44 payload
payload out into space just as a quick
reminder at the request of our customer
we won't be showing views of the payload
so we'll be ending the webcast just
after our side boosters make their way
back to land at lz1 and lz2 and that
will be a little after the t plus eight
minute Mark into flight stage two locks
load is complete so there we heard the
call out stage two locks load is
complete so at this point in time Falcon
heavy is now fully loaded with all of
its propellants as I mentioned as I've
mentioned before in previous webcasts
launch is hard Falcon heavy is no
exception for essentially counting down
three rockets simultaneously so our team
is going to be conservative in case
anything pops up in the last minutes of
the countdown
[Music]
in addition to the fog around the launch
pad we can see some of the white clouds
there around the vehicle totally normal
that's just the liquid oxygen uh
basically
uh vaporizing as it comes into contact
with the ambient hair now that those
Closeouts are complete as we just heard
back call out we should see more of that
next we'll hear the call out that Falcon
9 is and startup
Falcon heavy is in startup all right at
this point in time Falcon Heavy's
onboard flight computers have taken over
the launch countdown great view of the
base of Falcon heavy there
MD LD go for launch
LD this is the empty the MD is go for
launch
there we heard the final go for launch
in my 30 seconds accounting
let's listen in to the final count as
Falcon heavy gets ready to go to space
once again
15 seconds accounting
T minus ten nine eight seven six five
four three two one zero lift off
[Applause]
Vehicles magic down range
same with the chamber shaver pictures
[Applause]
[Applause]
pounds of thrust
headed to space
the throttle down in preparation for Max
Q moment of peak mechanical stress on
the rocket Falcon heavy is supersonic
there we just heard the call out that
the vehicle is now traveling faster than
the speed of sound but a beautiful sight
Max Q
all right there we just heard the call
out that is the moment of peak
mechanical stress on the rocket
m1d engines throttling back up
a beautiful sight to see Falcon heavy
flying once again
I surely we'll hear the call out for M
back chill indicating that the second
stage is prepping the mbac engine
Vehicles following a nominal trajectory
we will flow a little bit of the super
chill liquid oxygen through the turbo
pumps on that mvac in preparation for
the full flow of the super chilled
propellant
shots there of each side booster on the
right hand side of your screen
next event will be booster engine cutoff
or Biko
that'll be followed by stage separation
of side boosters side booster boost back
Burn Center core main engine cutoff
we are about 10 seconds away from the
booster separation
for separation confirmed
and there you can see and heard it by
the incredible excitement within the
crowd behind me successful separation of
the side boosters
there we can see three engines on each
side booster have relit for their boost
back burn
at this point in time both side boosters
are returning those are following
nominal trajectories good news there
both side boosters and Center core uh
everything looking good side boosters
are returning to the coast of Florida
now under the power of three engines
that's a view there of the center core
coming up three events happening in
Rapid succession we'll have the
conclusion of the side booster boost
back burn followed by main engine cut
off as well as stage separation of that
Center core
as a reminder for the request of our
customer we won't be showing second
stage views after second engine start
one additionally our Center core or
stage one the one you see there is
Expendable today so we are not
recovering this booster
foreign
shut down
Nico stage separation confirmed
[Applause]
there you heard the call out and saw on
your screen we had side views back for
him
conclusion as well as the main engine
cut off in separation for that Center
core and we heard call out of second
engine start one at this point in time
with that call out separation confirmed
uh we will wrap our coverage pertaining
to the second stage keeping our focus on
the side boosters which you see there
unfortunately looks like a position the
cameras on those side boosters are a
little fogged over
we heard a confirmation of successful
fairing separation
while second stage continues on its
Journey the fairing halves will fall
back to Earth where we will attempt to
recover them using our recovery vessel
Doug
as a reminder today we'll be attempting
to recover the two Falcon heavy side
boosters on land
you can sort of make out some cloud
coverage there in the background camera
we'll bring that back to you whenever
we're able now in just a few minutes the
side boosters will execute an entry burn
followed by a landing burn
both burns are meant to slow the side
boosters down rapidly before landing
at the time of Separation the side
boosters were traveling slow enough to
turn around and make their way back to
land at uh at our side-by-side landing
pads if we have successful Landings
today it will Mark the 150th and 151st
successful Landing of an orbital class
rocket
as I mentioned earlier Center core is
going to be expended and we are not
attempting to recover it this allows us
to utilize all vehicles continue to
follow nominal trajectories allows us to
utilize all the propellant on board and
deliver Peak Performance for the payload
delivery
on the left hand side of your screen is
a live view of Hawthorne Mission Control
here at SpaceX headquarters
we're about 30 seconds away from the
entry burn for the two side boosters
they're on the top and bottom of the
right hand side of your screen
foreign
side booster entry burn
[Music]
there we heard the call out that the
booster entry burn has the gun
thank you
[Music]
it's like the ice on those cameras are
now clearing NY FTS have saved
all vehicles continue to follow nominal
trajectories
so that re-entry burn has concluded
we're expecting the landing burn to
begin in about 30 seconds
the entry burn intended to slow the
vehicles down significantly as they
re-enter the Earth's atmosphere
amazing tracking cam
views of the boosters as they return to
Landing Zone one and two
we can see the grid fins there all Cloud
boosters transonic
stage two FTS is safe stage two is in
terminal guidance
we can see those grid fins steering the
boosters for a precise Landing again
we're attempting Landing
Landing Zone one and two
of it
cheers we have successfully landed both
Falcon heavy side boosters at Landing
Zone one and Landing zone two what an
incredible sight
with these two side boosters this marks
the 150th and 151st overall successful
Landing is an orbital class rocket this
is the 21st Landing at Landing Zone one
and the fourth landing at Landing zone
two
and with successful confirmation of our
side boosters Landing that will bring
today's webcast to a close we'd like to
thank the United States space force for
entrusting us with today's Mission thank
you to the range and FAA for licensing
today's launch and we'd like to thank
all of our viewers for tuning in for an
exciting morning now if you're
interested head over to our website and
social media platforms for updates on
our next missions and Milestones hope to
see you soon enjoy the rest of your day
foreign
[Music]